So using just the information you had in the
pedigree here, you should have been able to figure out
that unaffected parents have affected children, and that the trait
seems to skip generations. Now let's take a look at
each of these over here. We see that unaffected parents,
look at Kate's parents: she has an unaffected mom and
an unaffected dad, but she's affected. And then look at
her dad's sister, who was affected, right, her paternal aunt.
Both of her parents were unaffected. This appears to be
true in our pedigree here. The second option is that
affected parents have affected children. In no circumstance do we
see, although we only have one to look at, Kate's
maternal grandfather, where he's affected but his daughter is not
affected. This would be Kate's mom. So let's go to
the third and fourth options we could have chosen here.
And we look at the trait itself, the shaded box,
the shaded square here. And we see that it
did not get passed down to the daughter, and then
did get passed down to the granddaughter. This fully
skipped a generation. So this is obvious here that the
trait does skip generations. This particular pattern of inheritance
Could seem a little confusing at first. Especially if yo're
new to this. But, understanding how a genome is transmitted
from parents to chilrens, is going to help us answer many,
many more questions about other traits in coming lessons.